évidemment charlet jet mentaliser après
ça c'est sûr mais avant je n'étais pas
fait venir que pour rien j'essaie de
m'intéresser à cet univers là je regarde
des vidéos depuis février maintenant et
je cherche des conseils pour moi en tant
que mec qui signe et je ne trouve pas
grand chose alors que je suis sûr que
les meufs comme toi vous avez plein de
vrais conseils
ok donc cette vidéo va être sur des
conseils beauté sur moi avant la
métallisation si jamais vous ne voulez
pas voir ça c'est fait comment arrêter
de regarder cette vidéo tout ça tout de
suite
mais à 30 % de filles sur ma chaîne et
je suis sûr que parmi les mecs il ya des
mecs qui comme moi ont des problèmes de
peau de cheveux de j'en sais rien en
faire mais oui maquillage salue
aujourd'hui je suis avec charles et de
la chaîne je suis modeste comme moi
aussi je suis modeste on s'est dit
c'était peut-être cool de faire une
vidéo ensemble alors charles hey toi tu
as une chaîne sur l'hypnose exactement
les gens avec la beauté une fille trop
bien passé une chaîne beauty tu fais un
peu de 10 à higuain aussi je crois je
fais beaucoup de dialogues en fait le
truc c'est que je fais tous mes
cosmétiques maison
nous on s'est rencontrés via une amie
commune et issia de le corps la maison
le corps la maison à l'esprit et on
avait fait une vidéo qui est juste là
ensemble tout début de la chaîne j'avais
fait ça elle m'a dit et fabien il faut
absolument que charles et à être trop
gentille
parce que moi je trouve tout le monde
trop gentille et espagnols se rencontrer
comme ça et du coup on a monté un crew
on a monté un network
c'est notre network c'est des
conversations facebook et 83 jusqu'à 3
vous pouvez pas vous insistez c'est mort
tu m'observe tu m'as d'alizée tu dis ce
que tu peux faire pour moi bah non parce
que si je constate des problèmes que
j'ai comme une marque de démarcation ça
c'est tout simplement tes cheveux n'ont
cessé mes choix ouais ça sera en fête le
soleil du tout voilà donc battu le même
temps que je sorte en mettant des
barrettes
voilà je suis tu te fais un serre-tête
il ya des 10es pour sa survie du très
joli certes m
partie diabaye srpj maillon super g avec
un saut m'a offert un gel à la fraise
qu'elle a fait elle même
du coup j'ai pas osé demander les
ingrédients pour faire du gel un trop
chou
alors voilà vrai problème j'ai la peau
très sèche tenue d'une idée à ce matin
ah ouais mais l'univers c'est pas super
bon non plus en fait à deux je vais
commencer à être chiante ta de lille
minérale dedans en fait qui te permet de
faire un gros film sur ta peau donc ça
va la protéger des agressions mais tout
ce que tu vas essayer d'apporter
hydratation nutrition ce que tu as
besoin
ben salah reste en surface en fait et ça
tout ce que tu fais ça sert à rien
d'accord voilà je les em je t'ai pas bah
voila je vais rester expo lieta peau est
en fait pour les personnes liées à leur
attention parce qu'on utilise des termes
que je ne connais pas alors expédié
c'est simple tu prends bayal comme la
maison l'esprit en plus qui fait des
trucs simples comme ça tu prends du
sucre tu prends de l'huile par exemple
de l'huile d'olive
c'est mortel goethe expo lille à pau en
fait je prends le sucre au creux de ta
main tu mets un petit peu d'huile mais
un tout petit peu tu vas tout doucement
frotter le sucre imas 10 de 8 va se
dissoudre nature en dé toutes les
cellules mortes et c'est et raturer
wargaming net et ensuite pour l'hydrater
en tête ce qui est chiant
surtout qu'on est à paris tall calcaire
prend du mot floral tu sais ce que c'est
une eau florale
tu vois avec tu vois des fleurs je vois
de l'eau et bennoo floral quoi ok
d'accord basse et sa voile à l'eau en
fait c'est éviter totalement de rentrer
en contact avec l'eau qui sort de ton
robinet c'est chiant c'est drôle parce
que je suis sûr que tous les mecs de
cette chaîne se disent comme moi bah je
suis déshydraté ben je met de l'eau bah
ouais non non non non en fait ça
déshydrate encore plus sain plus tu met
de l'eau plus à déshydrater pour ça
c'est quand tu sors de ta douche des
fois deux minutes après ouais ouais ça
tiraille est en fait l'eau qui reste sur
le visage et c'est faux tout de suite
les plongées pas l'essayer l'épongé
parce que si tu la gardes jeu c'est son
truc très bizarre plus l'eau aspire plus
bas c'est n'importe quoi
enfin l'eau calcaire du robinet je
laisse tomber dans nivea
tu laisses tomber ces morts et un pirate
et à pau avec une vraie crème mais c'est
quoi une vraie crème du peut pas sinon
je t'en fais une tu m'en fais une
tempête sur la chaîne doit je vais voir
sur ta chaîne en face nice hormis tu
l'as fait c'est très sain de corps et la
protéger du soleil au balajo isolé
j'habite à paris comme ça ça c'est
compliqué il pleut ne va mal on sait
jamais on l été et donc peut-être qu'il
va se dire on est passé l'été
aujourd'hui en plus pas une deuxième
question aura une deuxième question et
je pense que deux personnes sur la
chaîne ont ce problème
dites le nous dans les commentaires chez
de cheveux hyper c'est qu'on dirait du
foin en fait l'eau du coq est tout
indiqué hier ça parce que j'ai un
problème que je peux aller dans l'eau
kader jeu mais c'est de la merde
jeunes 1 c'est de la merde en fait de
danser un ingrédient même des gels
douches etc faut s'en séparer c'est
horrible c'est le sodium laureth sulfate
sans cercle vicieux
au départ ça va peut-être te faire du
bien timbrée ça soulage que ça fait un
effet frais et c'est dans la tête
mais comment te dire le marketing assez
bien fait pour que tes envies d'achats
quoi jeter l'huile de te dira c'est lui
qui me faut alors que tu pourrais
acheter des champions fur et à mesure si
c'était vraiment un champion très très
pour cheveux normaux juste arrêter ton
shampoing et en trouver un autre ouais
mais bien après attend recommandé ok
donc j'ai compris je ne prends plus de
12 et si je peux en prendre je jette
tous les produits et jamais de l'eau
déminéralisée exactement ouais c'est
[ __ ] que je me demande c'est un repas
c'est exactement sur un fer à repasser
la battue prends soin de toi comme ton
fer à repasser
merci beaucoup charles et s'écoulent
j'espère que ça vous a plu c'est
vraiment une vidéo différente
aujourd'hui
mais ça m'importait en même temps de
vous faire découvrir la chaîne de
charles ix qui est vraiment cool pour la
suite dans quelques instants
je vais mentaliser en tout cas je vais
essayer de le faire sauf que la vidéo ne
sera pas ici
elle sera pas ici elle sera sur la
chaîne 2 charles est directement cliquer
là et merci à vous de nous avoir regardé
nous avoir écoutés j'espère que vous
avez appris des petites choses durant
cette vidéo si c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas à nous dire dans les commentaires je
les lis tous et à nous faire savoir en
laissant un petit léger mais néanmoins
très beauty pouce en l'air avant de
partir pour foncer sur la chaîne de
charles et n'oubliez pas non plus de
vous abonner à la mienne parce que
mentale blog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an donc rendez vous demain à
17 heures ciao
on